let's bring in jeff passing the baseball
insider for the mothership i know you're
busy we appreciate you
carving out a little time here let me
start with what happened in houston last
night with joe kelly
nobody got hit but there was certainly
intent there
where where does major league baseball
stand on the retaliation with the
houston astros
dan intent is a really funny thing
because i i
you know i want to very clearly say i do
think he probably was throwing it alex
bregman
but brandon mccarthy who i have a lot of
respect for
and who was a major league pitcher for a
long time
said to me on twitter how do you know
and his point was joe kelly
is one of the wildest pitchers in
baseball joe kelly had
absolutely no control of his pictures
last night joe kelly is the guy who
during quarantine
broke a window at his house trying to
throw a change up
i don't know if you saw that video but
his wife posted a video on instagram
do you think he did it on purpose just
to give the appearance that he's wild
so when he faced the houston astros then
he would have
he would have a good experience it would
be the most spectacular long con
of all time and i absolutely hope that
that is true
uh so let's let's assume that there was
intent there
like you said didn't hit the guy didn't
get thrown out of the game by an umpire
i think if there's gonna be discipline
for anything dan and i you know i
haven't gotten this answered
yet talking with people who are in
charge of this sort of thing but i think
if there's going to be discipline for
anything
it would be for the benches clearing it
pretty explicitly states in major league
baseball's
113 page protocol do not mess around
when it comes to brawls
do not get off the bench do not
congregate in large groups
there was no social distancing being
enforced when these teams got off the
benches and were
sort of mingling uh and doing a little
baseball dance there
so i don't think they're going to be any
suspensions i've certainly been wrong on
this thing before
but i i just don't foresee at this point
mlb coming down with a hammer
even if joe kelly was throwing it alex
i think the reaction by joe kelly to
correa when he struck him out in what he
said to him leads me to believe it was
so stupid but that's why it leads me to
believe that there was there was
there was intent there yeah yeah so
um and i understand the intent he was
with the red sox who lost to the astros
in 2017.
now he's trying to fit in with this
year's dodgers saying i'm going to go
out there and i'll buzz the tower with a
couple of these guys and
and i certainly understand it but i
don't know what happens tonight when
these two teams meet i'm guessing both
sides both managers both pitchers
no nonsense i'm running you and you
can't afford to have one of your
starting pitchers
especially if you're the astros they've
already lost garrett cole
they've lost justin verlander you and
the dodgers can't afford to have a
pitcher suspended as well so
i don't know where we're headed tonight
but i'm tuning in i hope
i you know what dan i hope it's to a
reasonable place
where five ounce projectiles aren't
thrown 100 miles per hour
behind someone's head like i hope i you
know
every year when baseball starts i sit
there thinking maybe this is the year
where baseball players aren't going to
act like neanderthals and try and enact
frontier justice
via deadly like objects that that's what
a baseball is
and if that fastball had hit alex
bregman
in the head it can cause severe
and permanent damage and i just wish at
some point
baseball players would agree among
themselves
let's not try to hurt one another even
if you have been
aggrieved in the past let's not try to
do something that could
cause lifelong damage it's just
it boggles my mind that we are in 2020
and guys are stilling at one another i
understand that's how they've policed
the game
for for the entirety of it but still you
know the game's evolved dan in so many
other ways why can't you're loving this
one
yeah but you can't throw it somebody's
head i don't like that
you're able to throw that baseball and
the pitchers don't have to bat
because the dh and if you pitch in the
american league
i can throw at you and i'm not going to
get hurt my concern would be
if i'm the dodgers i'm dave roberts is
guys
we sent a message yesterday we beat them
we buzzed the tower a couple of times
i don't want any of my guys i don't want
cody bellinger going
down i don't want somebody throwing at
our guys because
that's the surprising part if you're an
astros pitcher
are you allowed to then start going at
the opposition because you have to
protect your own players
it's it's really interesting dan i'm
glad you brought up the the astros
pitching earlier
because they have so many guys on the
injured list now
in their bullpen i believe their bullpen
has nine
rookies in it at this moment and you
know
one of those guys just because of
baseball code in the way that the sport
is
is thinking to himself well i have to go
and
and show my teammates that i am willing
to stand up for them and protect them
and i hope i hope that cooler heads
prevail here
and that something like that doesn't
happen but you know
everything is set up for uh another
just weird and ugly night and
and i i would like to believe that
if there is a suspension today that's
going to be the sort of thing that
prevents that from happening
almost like joe kelly or other players
getting off the bench
uh are going to be suspended as a
preemptive measure but
do you really want to open that
pandora's box where you suspend someone
so something doesn't get exacerbated i
don't know if your major league baseball
if you could or should do that he's jeff
passing he covers baseball for espn
i don't know if there's a manager has
more pressure on them this year than
dave roberts
given the fact it's a 60 game sprint if
they don't make the world series
finish that sentence
if they don't make the world series they
will be
extremely disappointed but understanding
that
when you are in a playoff format where
you can lose in the first round by
losing two games in a sport where
an inferior team beats a superior team
two games in a row all the time and two
out of three all the time
uh i don't know if that is a fireable
offense
do you think he has the most pressure on
him is that oh
yeah yeah i think i think that's
absolutely because
let's remember what happened last
october
i mean if dave roberts had been let go
after that nlds game against the
washington nationals
i don't think it would have surprised
anyone and i think you
certainly could have made the argument
for it and
i remember sitting there writing that
column after game five
just the the number of things uh
that that he did that were questionable
and in the decision-making there
was just bad uh but dave roberts uh like
everybody else who makes mistakes has a
chance to redeem himself this year and
he is working with the most talented
team in baseball dan like that's the
thing
he's got so much at his disposal there
they have a finite amount of years with
cody bellinger there with corey seeger
there
you know movie betsy's going to be
around for a while and they have a great
core but
every year you don't win a championship
if you're the dodgers
you're not maximizing what you can have
which is something that's dynastic
that's how
good this core of talent is there they
can be a dynasty
let me get to the marlins here and i'm
still trying to figure this out
of baseball having a short term and a
long
term goal here that they had to look at
sunday
and say short term uh or long term long
term would have been let's protect both
teams
and you know if you have an outbreak
there's four
um and the phillies didn't get to vote
on this either
you know so they're facing them they
don't they have no say in whether or not
the marlins take the field
that day and then here we are the
marlins aren't going to be playing
baseball until next monday
what is bait there's so many questions
here um
they're not going to play 60 games no no
no
i don't think if you look at their
schedule right now dan they can make up
the games that they're missing
against the washington nationals that
you know there's an off day in august i
think there's
uh in an often august or september and
they can you know pull a double header
here or there um
but against the orioles there's just
nowhere that they can make up those four
games
so i think maximum right now you know
let's say they go to baltimore for
one off day but are you really going to
do that with two teams that in all
likelihood
are going to be either in last place or
really low in the standings and not
making the playoffs
no i don't think they're going to go out
of their way to try and get as close to
a 60-game season as they can yeah but
what do you do
as far as winning percentage if there's
other teams that don't
they don't play 60 games
dan we're in 2020
are you trying to apply logic to the
world right now
because if so where the hell have you
been for the last
four months i apologize i apologize
i i sometimes infuse logic into this
program and i apologize there jeff
when do the marlins play again
uh i don't know if it's tuesday i mean
right now they have an off day scheduled
for monday clearly all their games are
uh postponed through them but uh
at this point the questions for them are
how do they travel
how do they travel safely where do the
players who are covet
positive go do they stay in philadelphia
or are they able to take a charter or
a bus back to miami i i don't even know
at this point what the
what the plan is there they're exploring
all their options and
beyond that can they feel the
representative team
are they going to be able to get players
from their alternate site
in jupiter florida are they going to
claim
you know they've claimed three guys off
waivers already are they gonna go waiver
hunting some more like there are a lot
of balls in the air right now
and i wouldn't say that playing tuesday
uh
is by any means a guarantee for the
marlins that's unbelievable
it just and i if i'm a team you know
though
here's the thing though dan what like
what's the alternative i know i know
but i don't want to go to miami if i'm a
team i don't want to go to miami
i do not want to go to miami and then do
you not do you not want to go to miami
because
of what's going on in miami or because
of what's gone on with the marlins or
boats both
both and then you have bob nightingale
from usa today saying that
you know some of the marlins went out on
the town when they were
in atlanta i believe i get yeah i don't
i
i i don't know how true that is oh
really
i mean i well i've just you know i've
i've heard that rumor i've there are all
kinds of rumors that come out
when something like this happens and i
don't know if we're ever
going to fully know ground zero of that
outbreak
i i just don't if they went to magic
city for wings then jeff
then i think that we have a story dan if
they went to magic city for wings
then it was well worth it because l
duncan my l duncan my friend on support
center has been talking
up atlanta chicken wings for the last 24
hours with me trying to argue that they
are better than the wings at the peanut
here in kansas city and we are going to
have a wing off
at some point she wants me to come down
to atlanta to eat the wings that's how
much she loves the wings
wow uh i know you're busy thank you for
making some time for us as always jeff i
always make time for you my friend
thanks for having me that's jeff passan
he covers baseball for espn